like I I have a group of friends right
and when I walk into the room with a
group of friends I know immediately
who's going to get the most attention
from the guys it's it's not me right I
have like a friend who's like very very
attractive and I know when I walk into a
room with her like the guys talk to her
first because like girls you can kind of
just feel it but I almost wonder when I
hear like and I hear this from girls a
lot like I'm a 10 I'm a 10 I'm a 10. if
that's not like rooted in reality
because attractiveness like there's
numbers behind it whether it's just your
results in the world or your dating app
data or like the type of guys you can
get